- Bienvenidos to Taco Temple.
Can I take your order?
- Yes, hi.
[laughs]
How you doing?
Uh, I'd like
one King Quesadilla,
some steak tacos--
- Two churros.
- Hold on, man, okay?
I got this.
A grande rice pudding taco
with the chocolate shell,
of course--
- And two churros.
- You know what?
I'll take two churros too.
- Shut up, all right?
I do the ordering, okay?
This is the only thing
I'm good at.
Don't take this away from me
like you take away
everything else.
- What the hell
are you talking about?
- Guys, let's not fight, okay?
- I'll tell you
what the hell I'm talking about.
You think humans are stupid.
Well, just 'cause you have
green skin
and multiple brains
doesn't make you
better than me, okay?
All you ever do
is [bleep] all over my planet.
- Oh, please.
- Huh?
- I drove for seven hours
to show you the Grand Canyon,
and you didn't even
pretend to be interested.
- Well, it was a crack
in the ground, Jeff.
I mean, on our planet,
we fix those.
- Guys, can we please,
please stop fighting?
- Wasn't that, like,
eight months ago?
How are you still
holding on to this stuff?
- I'm holding on to it
because I actually
have feelings,
not like you guys,
a bunch of cold-blooded Nazis.
- Oh!
- Oh, great.
- Here we go again
with the Nazi thing.
- That's right, here we go.
- You can't just compare
everything you don't like
to Nazis, Jeff.
- It's lazy!
- Of course you'd say that.
[chuckles] Everything
seems lazy to a Nazi!
- Call me Nazi one more time.
- Oh, you see? You see?
- Do it again.
- Stop it! Stop it!
That's enough!
[sobbing]
- Sir, I'm sorry. I'm having
trouble understanding you.
Did you say you wanted
three burritos?
- No, we want two churros.
- Oh, I'll [bleep] kill you.
[all clamoring]
[horn honking]
- [screams]
- Come on!